[موسيقى]
مقاطعه صينيه تسجل مليون اصابه بفيروس
كورولا يوميا الاردن يحبط عمليه لتهريب
مخدرات بطريقه احترافيه الصقيع امريكا
والحراره تصل الى 48 درجه تحت الصفر هذه
الاخبار وغيره نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم
حول العالم من انتشار رائحه كورونا مجددا
اعلنت حكومه مقاطعه
الصين انها تسجل نحو مليون اصابه 19
اعتبارا من اليوم بدون تحديد السبب وصى
شكوكا حول مصداقتها بعد تفجر الاصابات في
عقاب تخفيف مفاجئ للقيود الصارمه في
السابع من ديسمبر الجاري
رغم ان المهربين حاولوا اخفاء شحنتهم
بطريقه احترافيه احبطت السلطات الاردنيه
اكبر واضخم عمليه لتهريب حبوب الكبتاجون
المخدره داخل شاحنتين قادمتين من العراق
دائره الجمارك الاردنيه اوضحت في بيان ان
كوادر الجمارك في مركز الحدود الكرامه مع
العراق وبالتعاون مع الاجهزه الامنيه
تمكنت من احباط تهريب سته ملايين حبه
كبتاجون المخدرات بما يعادل 1000 كلغ
مشيره الى ان الحبوب وجدت مخبئه ضمن شحنه
صناديق تحوي عجينه التمر بعد عمليه تفتيش
دقيقه لشاحنتين مبردتين تحميلان لوحات
اجنبي
الى امريكا هذه المره حيث امضى سكان عدد
من مناطق الولايات المتحده ليله عيد
الميلاد في اجواء من البرد الشديد بسبب
عاصفه ثلجيه اودت بحياه 17 شخصا وادت الى
الغاء الاف الرحلات الجويه خدمه الارصاد
الجويه الوطنيه
زعم قرصان الكترونيه او هكر انه تمكن من
اختراق بيانات 400 مليون مستخدم على منصه
تويتر مشيرا الى انه عرضها للبيع ووفقا
لموقع تايم ناو نيوز نشر الهكر عينه من
تلك البيانات مثل البريد الالكتروني
والاسم والاسم واسم المستخدم على احد
منتديات المتسللين لكي يثبت نجاح عمليه
الاختراق مشيرا الى انه وجه رساله الى
رئيس تويتر ايرون ماسك دعاه فيها الى شراء
هذه البيانات من دون ان يحدد سعرا لها
وقال الهكر انه لي يبيع هذه البيانات في
حاله حصوله على المال من الى الراس
وفي خبرنا الاخير رشه حال الاتحاد الدوليه
لتاريخ واحصاءات كره القدم مدرب المنتخب
المغربي وليد الرجراجي في القائمه المرشحه
لجائزه افضل مدرب لعام 2022 القائمه التي
كشف عنها الاتحاد ضمه 15 مدربا من بينهم
الرجراجي الذي قاد المنتخب المغربي
لاحتلال المركز الرابع في مونديال قطر
والمركز الحادي عشر في تصنيف الفيفا
للمنتخبات لعام 2022 كما ضمت القائمه ايضا
الايطاليه كارلوس المدرب ريال مدريد
ليفربول الانجليزي